j'ai une excellente mémoire rémy girard
a été profondément touché par son rôle
dans tu te souviendras de moi un film
sur la maladie d'alzheimer
moi je les ai vécus personnellement avec
mon pas eu ce genre de
c'est cette maladie là
oui parce que c'est c'est déstabilisant
pour la famille au dos parce que on on
reconnaît plus la personne pouvez-vous
me limited cassé il incarne un
professeur d'histoire émérite qui
commence à perdre la mémoire
une situation qui a des répercussions
sur tout son entourage extrêmement pour
les aidants naturels et quelqu'un qui se
choisit dans un moment de détresse d'un
proche et c'est très mal vu et c'est
préjugés parce qu'on se connaît par la
force des choses c'est sa belle petite
fille qui s'occupera de lui
chaque beaucoup pour l'infirmière entre
ces deux personnes que tout oppose se
noue une belle amitié
je pense qu'elle a beaucoup d'empathie
pour lui à ne pas confondre avec de la
pythie je pense que comme jeudi ont
beaucoup de choses à apprendre puis
cette relation-là et énormément de
douceur dans cette relation le gilet
maladie d'alzheimer style alice il
pleuvait des oiseaux amour de plus en
plus l'alzheimer et la perte d'autonomie
sont des thèmes qui résonne au cinéma
c'est toujours quelque chose qui est
derrière ces rebonds s'est dit c'est
quand mon tour
il ya toujours quelque chose de son
corps tu vois quand on vieillit il ya
quelque chose qui toujours et c'est paul
von réveiller ce doute là le film est
une adaptation de la pièce à succès de
françois archambault
au delà du drame personnel tu te
souviendras de moi aborde des thèmes
beaucoup plus large
une espèce de réflexion sur le moment
présent en fait
et l'espèce de justement de bombardement
médiatique auquel on est soumis qui fait
qu'ils ont vaincu les choses les spas
retraçant nous ce qu'on oublie ceux qui
reviennent nous hanter
malgré les thèmes durs qui sont abordés
il se dégage du film beaucoup d'humanité
et de lumière et syna by alexandre
charti radio canada montréal